I'd like to sort of summarize by ending
with the last situation in keflonia I
employed somebody to
help me build my house
and I
it was an English person down on his
luck not earning any money so I said to
him okay give me a price and I'll give
you the work
and I gave him thousands and thousands
of euros
well I was buying some sailing fans in
England and sending them over to
kefalonia
and with some Garden
material some sheeting that covers to
stop weeds coming through
anyhow I paid him twelve thousand
and he contacted me and said you owe me
another 150.
I said
where you've only gave me a bill for
twelve thousand
and I'll prove that but it's a bit Petty
asking for 150 Euros after 12 000 Euros
he said would you owe me it
and I said well all you've got to do is
prove it to me write it down or prove it
well again I'll pay you
so
this went on backwards and forwards it
and
he wouldn't do any more work on the
house until I paid him to 150.
I went to keflania and I called him up
and said um I can't find my fans and
shooting for and he said no I've got
them in a secret place and until you pay
me the 150. I'm not going to release
them to you
I said I better meet you then so he told
me where he was working
and I met him
and this is only a few years ago
0.06 then
and I just lost my I lost my patience
with him
my adrenaline was so wired up I got out
of the car
and I said
where's my materials
he said I'll tell you when I see the 150
and it was as we saw red flag to a bull
I was really annoyed
I got hold of him
I must have ejected him back a couple of
meters with uh
the push that I gave him
he didn't back down
and I didn't back down but what I've
done was I grabbed him pinned him to the
car that I was in
and said take me to where the materials
are I'll give you your 150.
and he looked at me and he said you're
just a bully
and I wondered about this a lot and I
thought
was I being a bully I don't know
it was the straw as they say that broke
the camel's back wasn't it I paid him
much more than twelve thousand twelve
thousand with just one segment
that was an 8 000 segment there was
there was lots but
um over 150 euros
I lost my patience and I lost my temper
I went back
to the dojo
and I looked I sent this picture and
said I'm sorry I Sensei I cannot come up
to the art and the wishes that you
wanted I cannot love the enemy and I am
me
I'm no better now than the 20 year old
Thug
and I realized that I'd been living a
dream
from
I don't know let me think
wow
at least
at least 40 years I suppose perhaps more
perhaps 45 years of doing Aikido and all
I've become was a person that could lose
their patience and lose their temper
and we thought back to grabbing someone
and using my power and obviously a lot
more power than just strength but to
handle somebody much bigger than myself
it was much bigger than myself
but to
drag him and toss him around
made me ashamed of myself
so I just wanted to to share this with
my patrons
in time it will go out to the public
so try to become
as good as you can
but try not to have the illusion or be
disillusioned that Aikido will give you
something that your genes will not allow
you to be
Aikido has given me a great deal and I
love it today as I'm as I did when I
first started
but
I also realize that I personally cannot
be what are Scentsy
hoped for us
can you